[Música]
eu não sei se vocês conhecem esse número
ou não mas no quênia e 700 crianças
ficam à frente um dia eu descobri esse
número em 2014 eu tinha 28 anos na época
eu estava empregada trabalhando numa
multinacional brasileira ganhando muito
bem e aquele número martelava todo dia
na minha cabeça não conseguia tirar
aquele número da minha cabeça entrava e
saía dentro da empresa para preencher
planilhas para fazer novas apresentações
de powerpoint institucionais para poder
entrar em reunião sem propósito
e eu comecei a me questionar inteligente
onde está o meu propósito não tá aqui na
rua falar fora está em campo no campo no
trabalho que realizava pelo menos 15
anos
trabalho social e voluntário
instituições no rio de janeiro cidade
onde eu nasci e onde eu moro
jô devem ter reparado com meus taxiar
que eu sou carioca bom estava naquela
fase que eu não sei se vocês já passaram
por isso ou vão passar ou estão passando
mas eu tava me questionando tudo que eu
proponho um acidente dentro da empresa o
que eu estou fazendo aqui é de fato que
eu sei fazer o que estou fazendo aqui
pode mudar o mundo está contribuindo com
algo para o mundo é o que eu amo eu não
consegui achar resposta para essas
perguntas
era muito triste na realidade era bem
france vice ea então à procura dessas
dessas respostas que eu comecei a fazer
um gay sou formada em relações
internacionais
e falei bom acho que talvez fazer uma
pós graduação que consigo ver qual é o
meu caminho que eu sei fazer o que eu
amo fazer porque eu tô fazendo aqui está
fazendo sentido na idade alguém se bem
no meio eu abandonei gay não deu certo
porque a mesma coisa me questionava
questionável e eu não conseguia achar
respostas a essas perguntas sempre foi
assim desde pequeno sempre me questionei
só que eu me questionar se eu não
consigo achar resposta eu vou atrás eu
tento mudar
webb foi muito bom pra mim por um motivo
eu ah eu abri minha cabeça e minha mente
eu descobri que eu poderia criar fazer
que eu poderia empreender mim poder ou
sofre nossa eu posso também que a gente
acha que é só para quem já está bem
constituído que tem uma empresa gigante
que já está rodando não posso aprender
eu consigo m abril também olhar para um
outro conceito durante uma viagem que eu
fiz através de bem nos estados unidos
que o conceito de férias voluntárias
eu descobri que eu poderia unir duas
paixões duas coisas que eu amo e que eu
sei fazer que é viajar e ajudar
aquilo ali mudou meu olhar fez o meu
coração literalmente bater mais forte
porque eu amo fazer isso e eu descobrir
esses dois conceitos totalmente novas
pra mim eu descobri que eu poderei
vivenciar essas férias
essas férias com um propósito muito mais
consciente
eu já estava procurando aqui no brasil
pelo menos uns dois anos sobre isso
achava que o modelo de intercâmbio que
talvez alguns de vocês até conheçam aqui
que é pra você é aprenda inglês e cujo
leões na áfrica do sul
tipo isso qual é o propósito a causa o
impacto a continuidade e efetiva em uma
viagem desse tipo
e aí quando eu descobri esse conceito
eu vou conseguir trabalhar com de fato
algo que eu sei fazer que eu amo que
está no meu sangue e que dá brilho no
olhar
eu fui agora preciso trazer comigo dois
loucos dos sonhadores e o trouxe
eu trouxe alice ratton minha sócia e
amiga de infância e trouxe o andré
franco que está comigo nessa aventura os
dois estão comigo nessa aventura eles
assim como eu acreditam também que todos
nós podemos e devemos mudar o mundo e
temos essa capacidade de mudar o mundo
a gente pode todos nós podemos aqui
então a gente começou a trabalhar no
modelo de negócios eu ainda empregado
trabalhando todo mundo dos 3 trabalhando
e começamos a trabalhar nisso
será que vai dar certo nunca sabe nem se
vai começar a trabalhar com um plano de
negócios e tudo mais
sem saber se vai dar certo ou não e eu
como a maioria dos modelos de negócio
visa testar e aí eu resolvi então
realizar esse sonho jogar pesquisando há
pelo menos dois anos que era testar esse
tipo de viagem ele a estatística que eu
passei pra vocês do quênia então estava
com a minha cabeça foi assim agora eu
vou pra esse país
agora pensei comigo eu na época 28 anos
mulher e foi falar com os meus pais eu
sou filha única a gente não sei se tem
filhos únicos aqui na platéia mas e sem
esse tem pais que têm somente um filho
imagine o coração apertado do pai e de
uma mãe que é que a filha entra um dia
dentro de casa faça em bolton pensou em
largar o emprego com carteira assinada
13º para poder abrir uma empresa é um
negócio que não existe no brasil e aí
pra testar esse negócio eu preciso e por
que ele é mas minha filha porque e aí eu
comecei a trazer todos os
questionamentos que eu tinha que na
realidade a gente acaba entrando num
ciclo é gente tá com 17 anos já prepara
o enem tem que fazer o enem na época no
caso do vestibular
você tem que escolher uma faculdade e
depois você se forma e depois da
faculdade você tem que ser empregado se
você não sou empregado meu deus do céu e
agora o que você e depois de ter
empregado tem um plano de carreira eu
preciso casar e depois ficava quando é
que vai ter filho primeira pergunta é né
e eu fiquei pensando em quando ela viu o
filho e vem o processo não vai ter outro
filho único é horrível
é preciso de um irmão e aí você entra
num ciclo
aí você precisa ganhar muito bem você
precisa comprar um carro novo que
precisa trocar de apartamento em
apartamento próprio e às vezes você só
fica aqui na meta financeira meta
financeira gastar e gastar dinheiro e
isso me deixava muito treino eu não
quero viver esse círculo automático pra
mim e eu trouxe tudo isso pra casa só
que eu tenho uma sorte muito grande e eu
amo demais meus pais porque eles sempre
me apoiaram em tudo eles são os maiores
exemplos meus grandes incentivadores e
obviamente que eles acharam lindo a
iniciativa acharam muito bacana então
tiveram medo afinal estou indo sozinha
para vivenciar isso agora imaginem só
falando em casa minha mãe levanta a mão
digamos assim fala filho eu quero ir com
você pra mim é impossível o que acaba de
sofrer o segundo maior atentado
terrorista da história do país foi
tentar de basquetebol agora infelizmente
virou o terceiro atentado ea mãe não tem
como você comigo é uma responsabilidade
muito grande mas a minha mãe foi essa
minha mãe eu não consegui nem ligar tá
lá ela não ir e eu com 28 anos e ela com
57 anos
partimos para a viagem que de fato mudou
a nossa vida nesse meio tempo a gente
começou e continuou trabalhando no
modelo de negócios comecei a ler todas
as críticas a esse tipo de agências
remodelamos estudos tudo vimos a
necessidade de capacitar cada pessoa que
pra que queria pra fora
vimos a necessidade de dar continuidade
a cada trabalho feito tanto no brasil
quanto lá fora eu sempre vou falar
brasil afora porque pra ajudar não
existe fronteiras
então a gente começou a trabalhar numa
coisa chamada empreendedorismo social
está falando muito de empreendedorismo
hoje né eu comecei a me dar conta que
estava virando uma empreendedora social
presente mas o que que é isso e eu
comecei a entrar em reunião não mais
para falar de meta financeira mas só pra
falar
de impacto social para poder saber
quantos professores mas iremos capacitar
quantas pessoas iremos atender numa
expedição médica de ver quantos
voluntários capacitados iremos mandar
pro brasil o pra fora e eu passei a
viver um sonho eu penso eu passei a
viver exatamente uma experiência como
essa estar com essas crianças tanto no
brasil quanto fora
o papa voltou e eu quero mostrar um
vídeo pra vocês
para exemplificar mais ou menos o que é
essa experiência
[Música]
ai gente a conhece
meu estilo é o fato de rossi
aquele parque são jorge
[Música]
produz o iphone and many of angel spears
ashton
a direção é de sam nicole ans ainda o
inep o rio piquiri
[Música]
aquilo que eles fazem é como se fosse um
vazio aqui te de pessoas famílias que
pagam lepra para poder deixar hoje tais
apoia até pessoas que não têm família
por uma balada jogo em alguns hospitais
que nem querem cuidar dessas pessoas
[Música]
ele celebra a equipe portuguesa afirma
tabela
[Música]
é
essa experiência mudou não só a minha
vida como a da minha mãe e como ela está
mudando de vários outros voluntários e
pessoas como a fé passando como como ajo
na tailândia como a mara sarney com a
silvinha noite como giovanni na
indonésia como a marlise no sertão como
a jussara na qn como avic na amazônia na
idade são pessoas como vocês que
impactadas estão trazendo isso hoje para
o seu dia a dia para o seu trabalho
porque elas fazem para poder colaborar
com um mundo melhor para poder trazer
impacto e causa no dia a dia delas
eu só queria deixar um único recado
a gente tem tudo só de estar aqui hoje
poder chegar até aqui está conversando
um com o outro aproveita esse momento
tem interesse em quem é o próximo quem
está aqui hoje nós somos privilegiados
nós temos tudo isso e não vamos fazer
nada
não faz sentido não faz sentido algum a
gente não fazer nada pelo próximo pelo
mundo e tenho a certeza disso a certeza
absoluta todos nós podemos mudar o rumo
da nossa vida para mudar o mundo todos
somos capazes
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]